Elizabeth smarts father made headlines
over the summer when he revealed to the
public that he is gay and smart became a
national figure back in 2002 when his
daughter Elizabeth was kidnapped and
then she was rescued nine months later
now he's speaking to CBS this morning
exclusively he told us about struggling
with his sexuality for decades and how
very difficult it was to come out to his
wife and his children when I think back
to where I was as a youth I think 12 or
13 I started I mean I kind of felt like
I was a little different than others
that's different how different than you
know boys were interested in girls and I
found myself kind of more interested in
boys you know I did the typical going
out with girls you mean with girls I was
taught that having an attraction for
another male was not right it was
something that was not acceptable in
society in my culture and the LDS faith
at the time and I wanted to be accepted
searching for acceptance nearly his
entire life the Mormon father of six was
married to his wife Louis for 34 years
and when you met Louis did you think
she's the one I did yeah I mean really
did I just thought you know this can
work were you happy yes we were happy I
mean during the course of our marriage
you know there were times where I would
have these feelings come up you know why
do I find this guy super attractive and
I just wanted to push it down and you
know please go away I don't need this in
my life about four years ago and smart
says his wife asked him an unexpected
question my wife asked me
Edie are you gay now Edie why would she
ask you that four years ago why would
you most wives don't ask their husbands
that question yes out of the blue for no
reason right when she asked you if
you're gay what did you say to her I
said you know what does that mean
that's not a difficult question what did
that seems an odd answer to set does
seem an obvious but what does that mean
yeah does that mean that I've been
unfaithful to her does that mean that I
have you know gone out and been with
other men and and my answer with
absolutely not it never has been and I
bought that I don't think that people
understand the fight that goes on inside
and I mean I feel horrible that our
marriage has ended those is a wonderful
woman I wish somehow she understood I
think she believes that it was my choice
and yes it was my choice to end our
marriage but it wasn't your choice to be
gay you're saying it was not my choice
to be gay until I left her I was always
faithful and I can see that you're in
pain because of the pain you know that
you have caused her you know the
question came up you know is our
marriage a sham and I'm saying
absolutely not you know I loved you at
we had many good years together was I in
fighting this internal fight yes I was
Edie and Louis smart ended their
marriage this year but before the
divorce and still had to come out to his
six children at this point she said fine
go ahead and tell the kids and I went in
and called each one of them and this was
five o'clock in the morning you called
each child five o'clock in the morning
and that's how they heard I said you
know your mother and I are getting a
divorce
and I'm gay and how are your kids
supposed to process that because they
had it's like you threw a grenade in the
middle of an play yes that grenade had
been building for so many years that
when it had an opportunity of going off
it was it was ready to but did you ever
think maybe we should gather everyone
together and tell every I'm just sinking
being the child my other side of that
line right I wanted each one of them to
hear this from me and yes it would have
been nice if they had been in front of
me but I wanted this pain and this
struggle to be over with
what was their reaction anywhere from
well dad if you're gay you're gay
I still want you in my life too you know
the shock of your your what
your what how do you feel now that you
have really shared your truth you get to
a point where you sit there and say you
know I'd rather have the truth out there
from me then some rumor mail you know
putting something together that is just
not me when people say ed you have a
problem what do then what do you say
what was your problem I would say that
my problem was that I was trying to be
straight when I was gay that was a
problem what is next for ed smart I
don't know is it smart dating yes it's
smart is dating yes is it smart met
anyone that you'd like to tell us about
that looks like a happy smile to me I
think I will leave that privacy that's
smart okay but you're getting there yeah
I plan on being happy and I plan on
having a very full life and I I want
each one of my children to be happy and
I want Louis very much to be happy he
brought up his ex-wife Flo as many many
times because he's very concerned about
her he really wants her to understand
that what they had meant a lot to him
that he was in fact in love with her and
that this is just he's now finally feels
free it was good that we could end the
interview where he could actually smile
because it was very emotional a lot of
Tears during that interview and my heart
I have to say just opened up to him and
now you know he spends a lot of his time
when we were there in Utah over the
weekend he's speaking out to LGBTQ youth
into their parents he does seminars now
he wants to speak up because he doesn't
want people to struggle the way that he
did somebody those people will accept
him there was Tony there was so much
sadness it was so palpable in the room
you live a whole life you feel for not
being who you are no it was very very
difficult he has some repair work to do
with this family and you knew that but
it's not it's not a sham you know a
marriage is more than the bedroom yes
that's exactly it's a very good point
it's very good point